for this video i'm going to be
discussing the game that i i thought
um was the best this week there were so
many amazing games that happened
of course with the candidates tournament
and also of course
with magnus carlsen's um
you know invitation tournament online
with the knockout tournaments and such
but uh i decided to choose a game from
the candidates
because i thought it was probably you
know
one of the best that happened
and let's
hear some guesses i don't know if you
guys have any ideas of what i may have
gone for
we can we can try to get some guesses
before i actually
show the the game
nobody's saying anything but uh but
anyways
uh it is not one of the neptu although
maybe many of you were hoping it would
be one
um i thought i've already made a video
um from one of his games so i did not
pick one of his to be the my choice of
this week as the best game
uh so what i chose is actually
the game that was played between mvl and
funk
i thought that was
um a really good game to show
as the best game of the week uh i think
mvl had huge chances
to be um
you know a favorite for this uh
candidate tournament to potentially win
it he was leading the event right with
nepo after the first half
um he was in pole position but
unfortunately you know starting with
with two losses was definitely very hard
for him to
uh to come back certainly has had a a
tough tournament but this was a nice win
and uh van gaal unfortunately has had a
very bad um you know half of the
event and he did announce i haven't seen
the whole video but he did announce that
unfortunately he will retire
uh from playing professional chess after
this game so
it's a tough end but we know some other
players who have had tough ends
um actually no he didn't give up
but i don't know i i don't know
he he did say that he was going to to do
more coaching and such
i i would have to to check the whole
video
i i read the news um and
uh yeah uh
gary kasparov also retired well he had
planned to do that but he did retire
after a tough loss
against uh the polo so can happen to
anyone sometimes you just make up your
mind what you want to do and uh
of course it's bittersweet if um if it
happens after you lose a game but
um you have to remember life goes on
no matter what that's what chess teaches
us
there's always tomorrow and there's
always something really good that you
can do
and you can always change your mind you
don't need to give up
just completely we'll see what will
happen but
i think this is a really nice game and
let's check it out uh by the way
this kind of shows as well that maybe
berlin is not
really that boring after all
for those of you who know the berlin e45
knight of three knight c6 bishop b5
and here comes the berlin after knight
f6 right a6
would go into the typical relopez but
knight of six
goes into the berlin defense and this is
uh an opening that many of you probably
know became popular in the match
between gary kasparov and
vladimir kramnik
castle knight takes e4 b4
um
this is this is basically typical line
right 96
bishop takes c6 d takes e6 he takes e5
knight f5 this is all
theory and it goes on further as well
king takes the eight in here but there
are many lines that white can choose in
this position
i remember at some point i was
considering
playing this line for black
must have been at least 10 years when i
decided i considered playing it
um and then i was like no no i don't
think i want to play this
with black um so so what is happening in
this position because a lot of players
are thinking oh this is draw you know
just because it happened in the match no
no of course white still has very
a lot of uh very interesting attacking
ideas
uh blackstone is in the center
technically
white has the majority and the mobile
majority on the king side
um and black's majority on the queen
side is blockaded due to the double
pawns
but black does have the bishop there
right so we have a plus we have a minus
minus is is pretty bad the the fact the
majority is located
but the plus is is pretty good so you
have to figure out
what to do and um with black you can you
can choose if you're going to put your
king on the queen side or on the king
side you actually can do both and both
seem to to um
to be good um knight c3 is in this
position i think the most
played move um it's um
is the most played move but but h3 has
become more popular at the higher level
as as far as i've seen and there are so
many moves that black can play
if you are considering playing the
berlin with black you definitely have to
make up your mind of what you will do
but there are so many ideas
uh what i have learned that that black
usually likes to place his pawns like
this on dark squares
in general on that side of the board to
try to avoid
you know creating weakness like
not to let any weaknesses and sometimes
the king goes
on the queen side but as i said
there are many options um and so let's
let's consider a few of them in the game
king v8 was played by van gaal but
i want to discuss some of the other
options that black can have here for
example
uh bishop d7 this is an option
and um and the key this is an option
where black chooses to place his king
on the queen side
uh h3 is is a move that um yes does
allow some king h2 but also in the same
time support some g4 pawn push
and that pawn is protected and then you
want to move the knight and maybe a four
and
because you have a majority on the king
side you want to push those pawns
forward
but this is basically what you're trying
to get with white
so if you do that probably knight c3 is
going to be played
and then h6 is typical to try to avoid
some knight g5s and stuff
b3 and then this is kind of how you get
that position right king seat
uh king b7 this is basically
one choice for black another choice
would be
i guess h6
that usually allows rook d1 check and
then of course you go to e8 that's what
you choose to do
and then you'll put your bishop here and
the other one
and i think it depends sometimes it goes
to c5 b4 something like that but this
one usually
gets to be placed in e6 and that's
basically the reason of h6
stopping some knight g5s but also
supporting like making sure the knight
the bishop will be developed in e6
another move in that position is bishop
e7 again to proceed with the development
of the bishop and then if knight c3 or
rook d1 whatever
here the king will go on this side of
the board
and then usually black would play some
h5 the bishop would go here
i've seen people trying to trade the
rook in d8 and then
trade and then go with skin to see it
and bring the other rook on the d
file that's one option another move the
black and plays h5
yeah that pawning e5 is certainly a
little bit annoying
knight c3 and
i'm telling you like black sometimes
just chooses themselves to move the king
um on on e8 if they choose to keep it
there
and then finally there's 97 as well
as another interesting choice i'm not
that familiar with this move but that's
an option for black too
um anyways in the game king e8 was
played and now
mvl play knight c3 very natural
development move
and now h5 so h5 is
of course as i said previously an
attempt
to stop white from pushing g4 and
pushing on their majority because that
is basically what white wants to do
when they play h3 that's one of their
ideas
but it has a setback every single pawn
push
has a setback so you always have to
think a billion times before you make a
move
because it is possible upon move not
just basically any move but upon move is
also very important because you're
usually
leaving squares behind sometimes squares
sometimes also pawns and you have to be
very careful
with h5 you're leaving the g5 square as
an outpost
four white and he can take advantage of
it but that was the move played in the
game
and now knight back to
e2 b6
bishop g5 all right
so since black cannot castle anymore and
as i said he's moving the king away from
the d
file in order to allow not to allow the
check
being played um and also he's freeing
that square as this bishop moves away
he's freeing the
square to typically be able to trade the
rook on the d
file a little bit because of the pawn in
e5
um black is a little bit restricted but
in the same time the pawn being there
also restricts white's white from giving
checks on the e file
so they're pluses and minuses of course
right
um and so in this position
black
went for c5 which is very typical i told
you the way black's pawns have to be
placed
on dark squares there in order to kind
of control
a lot of squares and keep as little
weaknesses as possible
besides this bishop needs to be played
somewhere so
uh e60 will not do so much and they he
probably wanted
not properly definitely wanted to place
it in b7
and um
develop it control the long diagonal
control the d5 square which
is left once again as a pawn is being
pushed forward
it leaves squares behind so you always
have to make sure that those squares
are controlled um knight c3
coming towards one of those squares
and now bishop b7
now a very typical idea for white and
black has to be super cautious about it
is e6 once you choose to move the bishop
away from there right that's why before
i was telling you that bishop e6
is a typical move but once you've
decided to place the bishop on the long
diagonal
that is a move and a break that you
should always be careful for
uh rook f to d1
look into d1 would have been
i mean the alternative basically
um and it has been played many times
before
usually what happens after this move is
bishop takes f3
g takes f3 and c6 so
if you're giving up the light square
bishop and trying to mess up white spawn
pawns you should play this move because
otherwise of course as i said
the bishop was controlling the d5 square
now it's not controlled anymore and this
knight could jump around
and you really don't want to let this
knight jump around
uh now f4 so in a way this is a little
bit tough for white because they cannot
easily push
their majority they need to get rid of
the knight from here to push a 5e6 but
it's going to be a little bit tough
black is going to go and try to trade
the bishops
94. and as i was telling you this is the
reason why the king goes to the side
because
black is trying to trade now bishop
takes
and white does get filed temporary but
as you can see
knocking is seven and this will be an
idea later 94
as well and this was played
between dominguez and nakamura that's
pretty typical idea
after 94 black can also take here
f takes g5 and k7 and the point is that
you will
end up playing rook d a but you are
waiting a little bit because now you
want to try to bring the king
on a better location in e6 put some
pressure in the center
and then try to trade and you know have
a good position
so there are many options that can
happen and you have to investigate them
as you are choosing to play this line
for both sides so
once again pawn takes c6 f4
bishop e7 and now after 94
there are those two options for black
but anyways in the game
uh white chose to put this other rook
here
bishop takes f3 of course because that
was the whole point
you may ask me but why would white want
to let
uh black capture the knight and why
wouldn't they just move the knight
well the point is you cannot really
afford to make so many moves to try to
to get something from the position
because black can just try to trade you
and that that's very typical now you
cannot just move back you kind of have
to take king takes and now black is
going to take
over the file there's also king here
coming in
this bishop will stay pretty strong on
the diagonal
and this knight is also strong can come
to d4 so it's not
really an ideal situation to allow the
opponent
uh to get all of these trees given that
they're struggling a little bit with the
development
in that case after knight d2 it's
forcing the trades
and black would be doing amazingly well
so the thread would be one
bishop takes f3 g takes f3 and now c6 as
i said
uh it seems that in this position uh
mvl's
choice here was a novelty
he played f4 however he had
this position previously in a game mvl
against hikaru nakamura in 2018
they played in london uh rook d3
and the way the game continued is as
follows bishop e7 obviously black needs
to finish their development trade some
pieces
so that they can you know get the looks
into playing rooks are very important
rooks
need to get into play but now knight d4
rook v8 rook a to d1 was played to put
additional
pressure of course we're threatening
checkmate and you cannot castle i mean
how awesome would it be if you could
pass them but no you cannot castle
so black is kind of forced to take
unless they want to give up the default
which nobody
in their right mind would want to do
that because then you know
the rooks would get on 7th ranked and
there's 96 as well
and now this is kind of how the game mvl
against nakamura continued to trade
there k7
white brought in the king and now this
h4
interesting choice by by hikaru
and f6 and if you have the chance to try
to trade something you should do it the
knight went back and then king e6 and
and he had a you know balanced position
eventually the game ended in a draw
but this was mvl's previous attempt
but for this game he had prepared f4
and this is kind of an interesting idea
because
because you're supporting this pawn
you're supporting there you're not
really
showing them much but definitely 94 is a
typical
idea so bishop p7
when i first saw that move i thought a
little bit
of this move knight knight to d4
with the idea of attacking c2 and then
maybe some checks here but
um
but oopsie no i'm so sorry i meant
through d3
rook d3 would be would be the choice can
similar to the game and if you take
there i can go rook d1 and you have to
be careful with this knight because
we're starting mate
you have to go back and then there's
this b4 idea
followed by 94 and white is going to be
able
to put a lot of pressure it's not it's
not so easy for black to escape this
this situation i think
so d3 but in the game
bishop e7 was playing i think it makes a
lot of sense for black
to trade the bishop and bring one of the
rooks
on the default to be traded knight e4 so
far
i think it's very typical for both sides
bishop takes g5
so that he can free the square for the
king to bring one of the rooks and trade
them
f takes g5 is always f takes g5 when you
have double pawns
you're often thinking on how to undouble
them okay
so that is something kind of important
so it takes kinky seven
and now mvl
decided to go for the rukan games if
black was going to accept but he didn't
extend but that was basically the idea
right here
the point is not too easy to stop this
and if you're trying to double on the
file there will be rook d8
and then if you try to double takes
takes and now black and blinking is six
you have to protect it kind of like this
and now maybe knight d4
and it's not so easy for white to hold
on in this position because we're
threatening the pawn and we're threading
to a pawn here
if f4 pawn falls more paws are gonna
fall
so it's not it's not really a piece of
cake to play with white you're thinking
you have a better position but
not quite i mean after the bishops are
traded it's not that easy anymore it's
not that easy
you have to be careful with the trace
but i guess he had this idea in mind of
playing knight d6 and taking advantage
of the fact that black pushed this pawn
as i told you this opening is not just
this opening in general but this opening
particularly is very positional
every palm push could be
how to say i don't i don't want to say
devastating but
could definitely mess up a little bit
your position
i'm not uh i'm not playing this
this uh i i told you guys i was
considering playing it with black but i
decided it wasn't really
something i wanted to try but i need to
i need to remind you if this is an
opening you're playing or this is
something you want to
to plan you got to be super careful with
your palm pushes because
every pawn push leaves a hole in the
position
if you're not ready to to control it to
meet it
you may have some trouble
so knight g6
black played king here but the deal was
as follows so if
knight takes i think envelope wanted to
recapture with the rook
obviously because if you recapture with
the pawn again it's a palm push
and it stays as a weakness so black can
bring in the rooks and put pressure and
you may have some trouble here you may
have some trouble because that pawn
will not be able to be pushed forward at
all sort of tasty six
and the point is that now that's a
weakness
this is an idea so if you protect the
pawn
like this um rook d1
you can go to d8 and white
these these would be some natural moves
that someone can consider doing
but i want to show you how nice white's
plan is white can just bring in the kink
and then start pushing the pawns and you
cannot do so much
because if you take rook takes and now
you are stuck with the rook to protect
the pawn
this king cannot really help you much
you could try to just give up the pawn
on playing rook d8 but
really um i think the king and poland
game may be winning for white because
they have a mobile majority on the king
side and you don't
on the queen side so i won't take the
pawn to give you the activity
but i'll probably trade and win the king
and opponent games
end game so
a better alternative here for black is
rook d8 because if you take
rook d2 as i said previously so if you
don't take
rook d1
and the point is if takes takes and
andrew d8 i believe once again white can
actually have some
some potential ideas to win here you
have to be careful how you
what you do about these past pawns they
don't really have a past pawn
they can't really create one but just in
case you could try to play c4
you can place your pawns like this a4 b3
c4
bringing your king and you should have
some chances doing this with the right
that's how much would probably equal but
instead of playing knight takes d6 van
gaal probably thought after king e6
he will he will be doing fine because
trading the knights
you know not leading too much right king
takes
and then that's week this is week yeah
you get some activity but
uh but so do i i get to take one of your
pawns maybe i even can go to the iruku
d8 maybe not that one maybe or maybe not
maybe like more here or there to try to
take the pawn
and these two are attacked anyways
but rook d3 was played in the game so
mvl
followed the previous idea that he uh
utilized in his game against naka
um but now it's a little bit different
now
um the bishops have been traded off and
um
yeah from here
van gaal starts making
mistake after mistake and
mvl gets to take advantage of that and
you know finish finish strong this
assignment
though unfortunately not strong enough
to actually qualify but pretty strong
right
luke d3 luke h28
was um van gaal's choice
um knight xd6
had to be played in my opinion because
if rook takes d6 we take here you can
take in c
e in c6 and black can just either go
king of five which actually like very
much
or could go roxy to try to trade maybe
not this one maybe
actually it doesn't matter
that would allow some checks and an
activity that's just
you know king of five this makes a lot
of sense
and it's not so easy because if you play
h4 then king g4
so you probably have to give up the g
pawn maybe go some rook c7
bring in this other rook sorry all the
way to d7
or on the e file this is basically what
white should try to do
this looks a draw yeah
yeah kind of does look pretty balanced
yeah
this 96 seems very normal to be played
i'm actually a little bit surprised that
black did not do that because
you want to keep i mean you're playing
the black piece i i mean
i'm just saying from my perspective as a
at my level
neither one of the players were in
contention for for the first
for the first place so you have to play
the position
i mean you always have to play the
position but sometimes in some
situations if you
feel that your result could affect
the um the standings
in a tournament maybe you can take some
chances and can try to
to take some chances but if not just
play the position if you feel that the
position is equal
that's what you have to do but a lot of
us make this psycholog
psychological error we end up
just wanting to beat our opponent well
why
what did the opponent do to us that we
want to beat them right
i mean just try to play the position you
have on the board
if it's equal stay with equality and
and um
there's always another another game
later of course
but he played rook v8
if you want
now it is not going to be possible
anymore
for black to treat the knight that's
basically what i want to show
you gotta trade the knight anymore
because now if you take
one takes check and where do you move
the king if you go there there's
shank and uh i think we can check or not
check whatever i'm taking f7 and then
that's hanging everything is hanging
maybe we check it first there's no room
d7 but really it doesn't matter
you just take it right
so that would be a blunder you cannot do
that anymore oh wait
one more thing to show you if you go
here you can be d7
look there look here so many ideas that
white has
and you will not be able to get this
pawn
that's the big problem okay
so he followed up with this idea which
is also very nice
and he's was probably thinking ideas
like this to bring in the
roof but he still cannot take the knight
that's a tough it's a tough part
if you feel and if you see that your
opponent has a well-placed piece
and you have a badly placed piece try to
find a way to get rid of it trade it as
fast as possible
you cannot leave such an annoying knight
over there i think he probably missed
this move
and now it's tough to find a safety net
for the king
so f4 he played c4 here
trying to give himself a little bit more
space
if this one would have happened there's
this small tactical idea that i wanted
to show you because if you take
knight takes g7 check the king has to go
back
and then we'll take right and um
and we're winning
so luke 87 is a blunder you cannot do
that that's the problem
so he had to make some pawn pushes here
but he still cannot trade the knights
because
pawn takes in span and he won b5
okay so far so good it's not it's not
really that bad of a situation
king of two a4 all right he's plays his
pawns pretty well
he does not have the opportunity to
create a positive one
but he's plays them pretty well a3 and
if you
ever deal with such a situation just
remember this like
with white in order to stop black's
majority because you probably
are familiar with the end game you've
studied it before hopefully
like these three pawns here for black
these three pawns here for white and
then there's b3 and if you grab
foam with the c pawn there's a3 and the
c pawn wins and if you
grab it with the a pawn there's c3 you
have to take or unless we take and
promote
and then the a pawn wins that's a very
typical end game that you should have
studied by now
many times and so in order to avoid all
those situations
any kind of way for white sorry for
black to create a past pawn what white
does is a3 and if needed
they play c3 as well so if there would
be some c5 b4 and trying to create a
plus pawn you would play c3 as well
and regardless of where black captures
your recapture with the b-pawn
the pawns will be blockade is stable no
past pawn for black very very important
you do not want to let the opponent do
have a passport all right so g6
king of three and in this position
unexpectedly um
van gaal made the mistake after which um
he will lose the point is here white
doesn't really have big threats
um but um just
just just play to b8 just just sit and
wait
go to d2 you can go c5 or p4
and here it is different that he plays
b4 and even if you say oh i'm going to
play c3 instead to play c3 well be very
careful when i told you to play c3
please
okay because here is not the same here
uh
black and taken c3 or a3 wherever
somewhere
and there will be three and you're going
to lose a pawn so this is not the moment
they said to play
c3 you could play c3 before black pushes
b4 or
in a king important game when there is
no
extra piece that can come and actually
take advantage of those two weaknesses
you're creating for yourself okay so
very very important
but no like and if you play b4 um
we we can take actually with white of
course and then rook takes
and although black has those weaknesses
now he has some way to create his past
one maybe c3 and a
a pawn push but this would be another
game
definitely would have made more sense
instead he went knight g7 which doesn't
make so much sense because it's not like
what is black exactly trying to do i
guess he was trying to to maybe double
up on the default but
he doesn't need this knight to go away
he doesn't need to be double he needs
the knight to go away basically
doubling on the file 98
so it it helps the inevitable because
this is the inevitable rook to d1 the
knight was in f5
it had the opportunity to to be treated
for the night whenever they wanted
and what did they do black kind of
wasted some moves to bring the knight
there and now white is doubled
ready for the capture you cannot capture
anymore
and um and you wasted all the time for
nothing while me as white i've improved
my position
you know so knight c7
and um knight takes
uh b5
is the final move and
it is over
it is game over because now
you know discovery four key i'm taking
the knight with check
and that's that that was like the final
blunder knight c7
had he captured in d6 which probably
would have made a little bit more sense
rook takes d6 king to e7
and now uh
there are two ways for for white i think
to win this position
of course he's doing much so much better
first of all
mobile majority can still play king um
king e4 f5 try to trade and then and
then e6
or g6 to create the past pawn you have
to see
or uh c3 so so c3 is
is an option but rook takes the eight
probably works too
looking opponent game
and this should be this should be
winning i i haven't
maybe i didn't check it correctly
because now if the king comes in
so i'm attracting i'm doing this
triangulation so i'm attracting you to
push c5 or something
and then h4 i'm giving you the move the
king goes back for example
and then white king enters
the c3s are it's a really nice zugwan
kind of move
i'm going to move the rope because
there's a rook d7 check
so um but we can also win with c3 here
basically and then
if you go to here you know that key
important game is winning
and if you go here
and now f7 is weak so what do we do
we're bringing in
a new look into play right
and there's no way to stop that
that pawn is being attacked so you
cannot go rookie that pawn is hanging
so this was basically what happened in
the game and that's why i chose this
game in a way like it's
bittersweet for both players bank house
retiring
mvl did not have the chance to qualify
but unfortunately
that was it was a tough loss
since we still have quite some time
actually in this position
uh i thought i would i would go over
one more game that in a way
psychologically speaking uh maybe the
result shouldn't have been that but
um i've seen this happen many times and
once you see by whom the game is played
you will know what i'm talking about
so the game that i chose was between
ding liran and janna pognaci
and now you will be like what but the
end one why did you choose a game that
he lost
lost well the reason i chose is because
this was the final round so he was
already qualified he knew that he was
qualified
to be the candidate to actually you know
play against magnus
and psychologically that
is tough and this is something i didn't
quite like
in a way i have to tell you um
and that may be something he needs to
work on
i think it is very important
to have a strong nerve
regardless of the end i mean
regardless of when you qualify or
whenever
you win a tournament whatever i feel
that a real fighter a real
player should have the the strength
to play the same amazing chess as he or
she played
before the end of the tournament now you
guys
may not like what i'm saying but i think
that is important
so what if the tournament is one you're
still
a chess player you should still want to
win
like that is just my mentality it may be
wrong and
and you guys might not want to watch
this anymore
but i feel that it is important to have
that kind of mentality
that you play until the end and
you stay focused throughout even if the
tournament
is technically over for you because you
qualified i think that's
but um of course given the circumstances
that
you know kovid was happening and so many
things were happening
this past year um it is understandable
that
he wasn't as focused maybe or that he
lost
but um yeah you guys can let me know
what you think about it
so let's get started so this game was
kind of cool i thought too
um last round
he played some interesting line right
on g6 and e6 what do you guys think
about this
i don't know that wouldn't be my choice
uh that would not might be my choice of
opening uh
probably i would choose some queen's
gambit or slav considering that okay
maybe he didn't want to show any other
you know preparation that he
had
so you basically transpose in a way
into a um into a banana right
that's basically what what we can see
here right
it started kind of anti-groomfield right
because we don't know exactly what black
was planning to do but
anti-groomfeld slash kings indian
and it went into a benoni b6
bishop d3 bfg7 92 so far
like seems like very natural moves takes
takes
knight d7 right um
so benoni is technically not often
played at the high level
higher level i think um
it may not really have the best
reputation
if you're a really good and sharp
tactical player you can but if you're a
really good positional
player
i don't know you may avoid playing this
i think white shows a pretty good line
so uh
97 a6 and castle
are moves that maybe could help black a
little bit more because he
he definitely needs to play this b5
um and um a4 for example
97 now and and and that is the move that
black has to prepare to play
but he played knight g7 directly knight
e to c3 and i love this kind of idea
what did liran chose to supposed to do
because naturally you see
knight b to c3 but here since the knight
in b1
had not been developed he can try to
change
this idea and put this other knight and
this one could go through a three out
or three d2 you will see
a6 obviously he's threatening b5 and
white could stop it and they did
knight h5 all right castle
bd4 king h1 so far so good seems like
pretty natural moves black is trying to
get some activity
but what happened 95
and i back to you two sears thinking
wait did y just mess up
in that position they went knight e to
c3 should he have
gun knight c3 instead possibly because
with the knight here you're controlling
d4 and g3
but he felt that in this position he can
retreat
also white is not worried about giving
up the slight square bishop because
of all these pawns being on white uh
that is a bad bishop it doesn't do much
so if you
ever consider after having moved the
knight twice
you're gonna take why should be happy
because they only moved the bishop one
time
ninety two times trying to take
advantage of bishop being left in d4
because now
you don't really have a way to save it
back which is nice for us
so queen is four
knight takes d4 knight takes d3
and that was the mistake that nepo
made in the position it seems
natural one to take
and then go knight g3 and take the rook
but unfortunately this does not lead
to a good position black should have
captured here
now they're still threatening g3 which
is not so easy to stop i cannot play
queenie one because that bishop
will be hanging after the trade of the
queens
probably white would have to move the
king away
and then black would try some g5
g4 idea the king does not necessarily
need to get castled
he has some pressure he did lose his
dark square bishop which is usually like
better off not to give up or not to
allow to trade
but if he can put some pressure and
attack
white's king that is something that he
should try to do so c
takes e4 in my opinion could have been
the move
played by nepo but he went knight takes
d3 queen takes d3 and he went for the
material
a little bit too materialistic i don't
know
he's got to be more careful with these
things knight takes f1
and now white retreated with the knight
in order to try to win this knight the
next move and have two pieces for the
rook
head white taken here pawn takes
the point is that if you take here black
old castle this one is still hanging
there f five ideas
uh or just f6 to stop e5
and black is doing pretty okay the
knight c2 was
really a brilliant idea because now
black cannot continue this attack
very much king takes f1 and then okay
you've got one check
you go here we've got maybe one more
check and then we can just go key g1
and then there's no dark square bishop
anymore
and white can proceed with the
development probably bishop e3 knight d2
knight c4 knight f1
just bring in the knight to defend and
white should be fine
a black thought you know what's another
pawn i can take well
okay so you want some material indeed
but look at what's happening in this
position
black string is still in the center
these pieces are not developed
and this 19 h2 is trapped
so white should be super super happy i
think in this position
because despite the material
disadvantage
their pieces will be well placed
and let's see how he did it queen e3
nepo castle another move that probably
should have
waited a little bit because as i
mentioned previously this 19 h3 is
trapped
white is considering going queen f4
trading queens bishop f4 and then get to
win the tight
why would you want with black to give up
the knight
if you can help it if you can have a way
to hold on to the position and he did
have
g5 that was an option
f5 maybe was an option too but f5 pawn
takes and uh but g5
could have been an option and white has
to see this move
and then try to take but i've played
these positions before i gotta tell i've
played this kind of positions before
with white i had the opportunity to push
e5 take the pawn
but then with those double pawns if you
don't actually have a way to get it
promoted
it is a little bit tough it might not be
so easy
but um instead black castle
and i love this idea because the knight
is trapped and
he definitely wants to win it knight xf3
what to do he's just
trying to uh make sure that
um
he gets some material for the for for
the night pawn takes
and now queen extreme
obviously trading queens is not that
good of an idea
because um
now i just proceed with development that
is weak
and there will be other pawns that are
weak and black will not really be able
to take advantage of his rooks
and two two pieces two knights
specifically in a closed position
are super strong so queen h3
bishop f4 i i really love how ding liran
is
really playing this part of the game
just slowly finishing his development
not quite slowly because it's with tempo
but but black remains with these pieces
kind of restricted he went for another
pawn here but what to do really because
yeah that's hanging this can happen
you're kind of stuck 92 another movie
temple
when you sacrifice material remember you
want to make
as many moves with tempo as you can
because the more moves you make with
tempo
the harder it is for the opponent to
defend
f6
there is no way for for black to escape
with the queen
anywhere else if for example here
there's queen f6 followed by bishop h6
and
black may be getting mated uh pretty
soon
um if you go queen g4 check for example
to say oh i get to trade the queens with
check but
it doesn't quite help you because this
bishop takes d6 and one more pawn falls
and um white remains with these two
connected past pawns
they played f6
and now a beautiful beautiful move by
by ding uh queen takes g6
queen g3 was the alternative but i guess
he thought
he yeah he he thought
that this would be good enough
black does have two pawns for the
exchange
not for exchange black has a rook and
two pawns for the two pieces
but it's not so easy to defend have you
played look here
probably uh white can try to
get this other knight to attack there
rook will come to f1
white has a good position you don't
really have an easy way to
to get your pieces out b5 is also not an
option because we just take
take it and he's pinned we might even
play a5 at some point
and really white has a much better
position
lead you for
then i came back you know you have to
have a little bit of patience
uh king of pooh you may ask me why not
you have to well the point is that
after this he can try to take advantage
of the file
and play a five and try to trade and
then get in the with the other rook with
temple
things like that and you're trying to
avoid those things so knight d2
going for c4 and that was anyways the
place that we wanted to
to bring the knight and take the pawn so
black is stopping
and you see he didn't even rush to take
that pawn he could have but he didn't
even rush you play king of two because
he really wants this knight to go to c4
this is a very typical idea
typical placement of the knight in uh
in the banoni in in a lot of bananas
where they take in d5 you take with the
c
pawn that's a typical outpost you get
rid of the b
pawn sometimes you play a5 sometimes to
make sure there's no b5 but that is the
difficult location
bishop d3 91
c4 but now this bishop is in
in white territory whenever they choose
to take and bring the king to e3 and
grab that pawn
they can do it but he first wanted to
focus
on the weakness of that pawn now two
two and bishop c7
trying to support the deep one now that
king came in
rookie three
i thought this would make a little bit
more sense to take it but
rook e3 is nice too because once the
roux comes it supports the d-pawn
to go to promotion as well d6
no no no no you want to get your rook
active no i will not let you get your
rook active that's the big deal
rook case d3 king g7 knight c4
threatening knight b6
and black what to do here he sacrificed
the exchange but guess what
why did not take it white play knight b6
check and black resigned
the reason is if you go there of course
we take at night here and
you know we take their two and we're
winning
um and and if you try to go here we
still take
and then take there and then e5
and white is winning so
this was these were my two games that i
i really wanted to show you i
mostly wanted the first one i thought it
was kind of an important and nice game
kind of shows that the berlin is not
necessarily such a boring
drawing opening that you always draw and
things like that there are lots of
options for both sides
you have to know it very well if longer
time you didn't need to know so much
because it was
you know it seemed like an easy plan for
black you still have to know a lot
you need to know what the plans are for
white what your own plans are
in this one i think uh i wanted to show
it because of the psychology behind it
because
as i mentioned to you i think it is very
important to fight until the end in a
tournament
even if you have won it maybe that's
just my mentality and
i just wanted to share it with you so
that i you know i
i hear your opinions too you guys can
let me know in the chat
if you want um
and also um
i think it was really well played by
white with that with
improvements a small you know positional
uh
sacrifice control over the pieces in the
center
looking for threats plans
past pawns and that was the reason why i
chose this game
um
i really hope you guys enjoy these
videos if you have any questions
please send them my way um
i really enjoyed uh
making these videos for the club i hope
you all did too
hopefully i will be back with more
videos later but
until then please if you like this video
thanks for giving it the thumbs up so
that the club
um would know what
what videos you guys like and what to
make more of
um and um
thanks for subscribing follow us on
social media
and um that's that
and this was my last video for the
moment
for the club this month hopefully more
will come i
don't see any questions so i hope you
guys have a wonderful rest of the
evening
and i'll see you all very very soon
take care guys